speaking of redlining next question
please discuss how discipline equals
freedom
can and should apply to one's financial
life
thanks from all us troopers uh
obviously if you want to be financially
free you got to have financial
discipline
that's just the way it is so here's
it's it's just simple not easy save your
money
boom that's number one don't buy an ex
here's one
don't buy an expensive car
until you own a piece of property that's
just a basic rule
interesting yup if you're driving a
mercedes
um s-class from 2015.
is that a good one it's a very good one
yeah it's a very good one
but it's also 120 000
but if you're living if you're renting
the wrong move
sell that thing and buy a piece of
property
a car is a depreciating asset a
properties of properties and appreciate
any asset
try and put your money into your
appreciating assets spend
less than you earn boom
stay off the credit cards boom
invest your money in something
i like to invest money in me
in things that i'm gonna do that's what
i want to do yeah
i i want to invest money in things that
i know and understand and what better do
i know and understand than
than things that i'm doing for people
that i know or things that i'm involved
with
so that's what you got to do you want us
you want to get your money taken care of
you want to you want to have financial
freedom you got to just have the
financial discipline that's that's all
there is to it and work hard
you know work hard make things happen
but your
your major gains you know most people
don't become
rich by their salary right
they become they they earn their wealth
they gain their wealth
through bigger things like buying
properties you know we got a
jiu-jitsu player at the at the academy
a girl and you know a year ago
she was kind of talking to me about oh
well you know
you know she just got married and blah
blah and
we started talking i said you you you
know what the thing about move and i got
this condo and i was like we started
talking about buying properties and boom
she disclosed on a
like a four four unit property in san
diego
and the day she got the keys
she was making 400 a month she went from
paying 1900
a month in mortgage the day she made she
got the keys
all of a sudden that she rented that
place out she's got three units she's
living in the crappiest unit
and she's got those things rented out
and now she's making 400 a month so
that's a
that's a dealt of what twenty three
hundred dollars a month in the black
yep that's impressive yeah and it took
her a year to get done
but she did it and now i said she's like
i'm so happy i'm like that's cool
start saving start saving for your next
property i'm like the market's going to
take a downturn
you got to be ready if it doesn't if it
does but you got to be ready to make
that next move
so start saving your money start paying
that thing down start saving your money
start saving that next down payment
that's where your wealth gets
established isn't easy long-term
strategic moves that you make and you
know i'm no financial expert
but you don't have to be a financial
expert to know to save your money to
spend less than you earn
um and and property to me is a good
thing to invest in it does go up and
down
you know and there's a lot of people
that got crushed in the in the market
downturn
in 2007 and 2008 and i was in the
military so i was buying houses and i
didn't even know that the market
downturned it didn't matter to me
because i had a steady job and i just
bought those properties just to
just to have properties i wasn't buying
them to flip them and sell them and all
that no i was just like okay
in some some time in the future
somebody's gonna be paying me rent and
it's gonna go in my pocket and that
sounds like a good
plan to me because they're not making
any more real estate by the beach right
um so if so yeah
i'm not a financial genius talk to
somebody that is smart
talk to somebody that understands
finances but save your money
spend less than you earn don't be
renting if don't be renting a place if
you're buying out buying a mercedes
s-class
or a seven series or a range rover
yeah buy a little piece of property buy
a little thing yep buy a little thing
don't don't just just go buy that little
something get in there get it started
yeah man i like this invest
in yourself yeah because
and invest in yourself that's such a
broad term right it's such a
and actually it's kind of started to
become like a little
like a cliche catch phrase
invest in yourself but if you really
think about that
yeah you invest in yourself you don't go
by you know
i used to work in the nightclub industry
right so i'm and i'm now i'm looking
with my mindset now looking back
at the people i used to deal with i see
people see people come in there
every weekend and spend a lot of money i
don't know maybe some of them are
already a rich or but i know that if
that's what you're spending your money
on you're going out and
essentially just buying drinks and
buying nightclubs yes there's no
essential that's what you're doing
yeah you're throwing it thinking back
like thinking back
five years ago you
spent all your money not all your money
but you spent a bunch of money on drinks
and what you have literally nothing to
show for it and in most cases
it's gonna mess you up in in one way
yeah you can do something you regret or
whatever potentially
so think of that same five years and be
like dang what if i started these two
things that in my you know prediction
is gonna help me in five years and let's
say you did that five years ago
and you did it i don't know you even
practice it like an hour a day
whatever it is even just improving your
knowledge on
the economy or something i don't know
anything anything that improves your
knowledge
five years later you could you could be
essentially an expert at it
absolutely so now now just consider now
what is
it that you should have got into because
you probably have a handful of interests
that are pretty cool to you
even if it's like playing guitar i don't
know whatever but if you can make it
something that you can anticipate in
five years it's gonna be
you're if you're talking about financial
stuff it's gonna help you make money
didn't do that do that thing don't
and i i i harp on reality tv a lot but i
think it kind of deserves it
because you don't learn much reality tv
yet you lost like that hour
and if you spent that hour
and really you could kind of keep
watching reality if you want but just
spend that one hour
doing something that you anticipate if
you're really good at
it would help you financially do that
thing for one hour
and then i like it one day's gonna come
you're gonna think back oh
look just the same way i'm thinking back
of the five years ago i mean in my case
more than five years ago but
just the same way i'm thinking back of
those people at the nightclub industry
same way i'm thinking back about that
you're gonna be thinking back at
yourself and you'll be like dang i'm so
happy i got into that
you know yeah and there's all kinds of
things you could have done i mean i
look at the money i wasted over the
years in the bars
it's ridiculous you know being a young
seal out getting after it with the boys
thursday friday saturday and the sunday
that's how we used to roll yeah that's
how we used to roll
and it was just hey we show up i'm the
richest guy in the world yeah
i have all the money that i ever need
and i can buy whatever i want that's
what every
night was like so not wise
don't do that yeah and i'll even
go out have some fun it's cool you can
still right
i'm just saying think of that yeah think
of what you're doing right now and
you're
because for these people and for these
people i was talking about back when i
used to work in the nightclub industry
they are really technically they are
committed to spending their money
committed to it if you're doing
something to
every single week for years you're
committed to it
so just take one of those hours yeah or
take maybe 10
of that money that you're spending or 25
all of it whatever
and put it in something that you
anticipate yeah and the other thing is i
mean
invest in yourself is like actually
build something actually build a little
company
you know make something that's what
that's what i was meant you've got
another perspective which is also
very viable and makes just as much sense
i was
literally talking about you know from
your perspective oh you like guitars
cool
figure out how to make a cool guitar
stand at your house you know
and then see if you can get that thing
produced
and then oh it's really good maybe we
start running production
let's do that that is infinite not only
not only will you
possibly end up with some kind of a
product that sells
but you'll have learned something you've
had fun you've created something for the
world you've you've
learned the lessons that you learned
about building it and getting after that
that's all going to be worthwhile as
well
so there's no this this i'm not saying
this
um with regards to that you're gonna
come up with this product and you're
gonna get rich it's not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen but can you
use that to build knowledge can you use
that
to gain experience that will then
compound with other things in your life
and eventually make you financially free
because you had that discipline
absolutely
answers yes